[Musique]
c'est un plaisir de vous rencontrer
monsieur d'holbach les sculpteurs dunbar
et là ce soir
ok ça suffit on y va il me faut un
autographe les fenêtres ipam vértiable
je suis son plus grand fan a rédigé
difficile de trouver les maisons de
stars j'utilise l'appli tarn ap
tu dois faire super attention je veux
pas qu'on accuse de harcèlement et tu
peux pas venir chez moi me chercher
c'est ma résidence privée écoute mon
pote je sais pas comment tu m'as trouvé
mais je veux plus jamais te revoir dans
ce dernier
[Applaudissements]
ap
[Musique]
et
koné je voulais juste un autographe
à temps non pas tant est un grand malade
à